este pequeño gesto implicará también
esta nueva realidad los centros de
control y prevención de enfermedades
informaron el jueves que las personas
inmunizadas no estarán obligadas a usar
tapabocas en interiores y todo el que
esté vacunado por completo podrá
participar en actividades en interiores
y exteriores grandes o pequeñas sin usar
mascarilla o respetar la distancia
física es una más de las propuestas de
las autoridades en su afán de incentivar
a los estadounidenses a vacunarse e
incluso se está ofreciendo vacunas
gratis a los turistas debido al riesgo
de caducidad de las dosis y el costo que
implica mantener las condiciones
logísticas para mantenerlas refrigeradas
en nueva york se ofrecen tiquetes de
metro sin costo a todos aquellos que
quieran inocularse el antídoto y en
miami se aplica a todos los que pasen
por el aeropuerto tras conocer el
relajamiento del uso del tapabocas el
presidente joe biden declaró que es un
hito para el país si bien quiso recalcar
que cada ciudadano es responsable de
hacer un uso adecuado de la medida joyce
es la elección es vuestra todos vosotros
hacéis que esto sea posible ahora
acá vemos el trabajo de ganar al virus y
hacer que todo vuelva a la normalidad el
uso del tapabocas ha provocado una
polarización en la sociedad
estadounidense alentada por los
comentarios en su contra del
expresidente donald trump
en su discurso baiden hizo también un
llamado a que esta medida no cause más
confrontación y red su match cambia
hemos tenido demasiado conflicto
demasiada amargura demasiada ira
demasiada polarización por el uso del
tapabocas as pese a todo se sigue
recomendando el uso de mascarillas en
medios de transporte colectivos y
seguirá siendo obligatorio en hospitales
o residencias de ancianos debido al
riesgo de contacto para otras personas